incendie monstre en espagne dans la
région de barcelone en trois jours
treize mille hectares de forêts sont
déjà partis en fumée
le feu ont-ils s'étendre ce soir le
raz-de-marée en papouasie nouvelle
guinée les premiers témoins racontent le
déferlement des vagues hautes de 10 m on
parle d'au moins 3000 victimes dopage
dans le sport après l' affaire festina
la ministre marie george buffet va
présenter un projet de loi pour
renforcer les contrôles et les rendre
surtout plus efficace vague de chaleur
moment année en france près de 40 degrés
à tarbes clermont ferrand du soleil en
normandie
pas de quoi se plaindre sur ce beau mois
de juillet en plein été les modèles
haute couture de l'hiver prochain défi
aujourd'hui christian dior qui avait
choisi pour décor les quais de la gare
d'austerlitz a pas madame monsieur
bonsoir les phénomènes climatiques
dominent l'actualité de ce début de
semaine en france avec la chaleur
revenue très loin de nous en papouasie
nouvelle guinée avec ce terrible raz de
marée et à nos frontières avec la
propagation des feux de forêt à
l'intérieur des terres en espagne dans
la région de barcelone 13 mille hectares
ont déjà été ravagés là bas en trois
jours par comparaison le terrible
incendie du var en 1990 avait entraîné
la destruction de 15 mille hectares en
deux semaines ce sont les régions du
nord de la catalogne qui sont touchés
mille sauveteurs sont sur les lieux
assisté d'une vingtaine d'avions à
l'origine des incendies la sécheresse la
chaleur mais peut-être aussi des départs
de feu d'origine criminelle
agnès varda
en trois jours les pompiers espagnols
n'ont rien pu faire
la sécheresse 40 degrés à l'ombre le
vent est un front des incendies long de
25 km ont eu raison de leurs efforts là
où le feu passe les arbres brûlent comme
des tanches hier de pompiers ont trouvé
la mort
leur hélicoptère a heurté une ligne
haute tension
dépassés les secours font appel aux
volontaires
il demande aux simples citoyens mais
aussi aux propriétaires de camions
citernes de les rejoindre avec de l'eau
car il en manque
mais ce système s'est révélé peu
efficace des habitants arrivent
oui mais dans le désordre sans moyens et
le feu progresse la france a envoyé
trois canadair en renfort en 94 des
incendies semblable en catalogne avait
ravagé 80 mille hectares de forêt
cette fois ce sont trois feux
différentes qui se sont rejoints pour
créer un seul fonds leur fumée est
d'ailleurs visible à 50 km de là depuis
la france
leur cause est l'espagnol parle pour
l'instant plus d'actes délibérés que d'
imprudence après le raz-de-marée qui a
dévasté la côte nord de la papouasie
nouvelle guinée les informations qui
nous viennent de là-bas révèle l'ampleur
de la catastrophe on a même évoqué un
nombre de victimes aux alentours de 3000
voire plus ce qui s'explique parce que
les témoins racontent que la côte a été
ravagés par des vagues hautes de 10
mètres déclenchée par un tremblement de
terre qui ait lieu au large du continent
la mère submergeant la côte sur un front
de 30 km
thierry courtin les premiers survivants
sorte de la jungle et retrouvent leurs
villages dévastés
la plus grosse des trois vagues de dix
mètres de haut 30 mètres de large s'est
enfoncée jusqu'à 2 km dans les terres à
cause de la chaleur les secouristes en
terre les corps à la va vite dans le
sable sur la plage pour éviter qu'il ne
soit la proie des charognards
il n'y a pas encore de bilan officiel je
vais vous donner un bilan approximatif
d'environ 3000 morts n vous avez
localiser tous les corps les corps sont
sous les gravats dans la mangrove
enchevêtrés avec les débris de bâtiments
de cocotiers et toutes sortes d'arbres
qui ont été arrachés et noyé dans le
lagon c'est trop difficile à ce stade
plus d'une école plus un seul bâtiment
intact
la première chose qui choque les
secouristes et bien sur l'étendue du
désastre mais aussi et surtout le petit
nombre d'enfants parmi les rescapés
beaucoup de ceux qui n'étaient pas avec
leurs parents nos sans doute pas eu le
réflexe de se sauver
la plupart des blessés souffrent de
fractures multiples les membres martelé
par la vague
les arbres et les débris qu'il charriait
secours s'organisent il faudra du temps
pour que la mer rendent tous les corps
pour que le bilan soit définitif
sur un marais était-il prévisible
comment les spécialistes chargés de les
détecter sont ils équipés reportage de
josé blanc lapierre et jocelyn
lermusiaux aucun mouvements de l'écorcé
terrestre aussi infime soit il n'échappe
à ces ordinateurs 24 heures sur 24 les
vibrations du sous sol sont surveillés
dans ce laboratoire du cea le séisme de
nouvelle guinée a été ressenti jusqu'en
france
on le retrouve sur ses courbes qui
mesure le sous-sol de l'hexagone 17
juillet 11 heures heure française les
ondes s'amplifie preuve qu'un séisme
s'est produit quelque part c'est pas
prévoir les séismes donc il y à des
activités de recherche qui sont en cours
par contre on ne sait pas le faire de
façon opérationnelle on ne sait pas
prédire un séisme par contre ce que l'on
peut faire c'est fournir très rapidement
une localisation précise de l'épicentre
donc de la localisation du séisme
car l'origine la plus courante d'un
raz-de-marée c'est le séisme au fond de
la mer la terre tremble en surface l'eau
se déforme l'ondé de choc se propage
quand elle touche la terre c'est le
raz-de-marée
cette déformation a engendré une vague
qui s'est propagé au travers de domaines
océaniques à une vitesse de l'ordre de
quelques centaines de kilomètres par
heure
et elle a atteint par en particulier les
côtes du japon
cette simulation le raz-de-marée qui a
détruit la ville de lisbonne c'était en
mais le plus important s'est produit au
chili en 1960
l'ondé de choc avait traversé le
pacifique en france beaucoup moins
dramatique est beaucoup plus normal pour
la saison une vague de chaleur
momentanée nous disent des spécialistes
s'est abattue sur le pays notamment en
auvergne il a fait près de 40 degrés à
l'ombre aujourd'hui à clermont ferrand
et non loin de là dans le cantal à saint
flour
ce sont 73 jeune fille d'un camp de
scouts qui ont été victime hier d'un
phénomène de déshydratation aujourd'hui
heureusement cinq d'entre elles
seulement demeure en observation
reportages et au lamberton françoise
masse où les responsables du camp de
scouts étaient ravis d'avoir trouvé
cette colline pour célébrer la messe
surplombant les monts du cantal le site
est une invitation à la contemplation
mais il avait oublié une réalité bien
terre à terre et pourtant deux
taille la canicule résultat après avoir
prié hier midi pendant plus d'une heure
sous un soleil de plomb et sans ombre
le ciel leur est tombé sur la tête 72
adolescentes sont prises de malaises
victimes de ces verres insolation elles
sont évacuées vers les hôpitaux de la
région
avoir la tête qui tournait il peut
trembler un peu n'avait très soif je
veux pas boire ou pas oui
après avoir passé quelques heures aux
urgences les jeunes filles ont rejoint
aujourd'hui leur camp non sans avoir été
sermonné par les médecins sur les règles
à suivre en cas de forte chaleur il faut
éviter surtout en particulier parce un
peu fragiles âgées ou les enfants d
exposer trop longtemps au soleil et
surtout savoir qu'en cas de chaleur il
faut soit se couvrir et bien sûr mais
aussi savoir qu'il faut au moins boire
un litre et demi d'eau par jour ou plus
sur la sphère des efforts physiques
en fait la canicule s'est abattue d'un
coup sur l'auvergne entre samedi et
dimanche le thermomètre a grimpé de 10
degrés pour atteindre 37 degrés demi
aujourd'hui au tour de clermont ferrand
à châtel guyon la piscine municipale est
prise d'assaut déjà vu ça ici à châtel
guyon
je suis heureux comme ça non
longtemps devant
et cramant l'auvergne a été aujourd'hui
la région la plus chaude de france mais
la canicule sera de courte durée car
selon météo france dès demain n'appuie
devrait venir à fraîchir les volcans
alors ne soyons pas chagrin cette vague
de chaleur fait des heureux les
vacanciers de la mer du nord et de la
manche qui avait connu un 14 juillet au
10 ans autant dire que le soleil revenu
à peupler les plages et les terrasses de
cafés et restaurants patrick fondions
alice betula voilà vingt jours qu'on
l'attend de pied ferme l'été sur la
plage de cabourg 20 jours on en rêve 20
premiers jours de vacances gâchées
alors mes premiers vrais rayons du
soleil ont surpris mais ils n'ont fait
que des heureux par rapport aux cavs
derniers jours paradisiaque ça on
passait nos quinze premiers jours de
vacances sur les côtes d'armor et c'est
froid depuis deux jours pendant un mois
il n'y a pas eu de soleil là c'est le
premier week-end con que je peux passer
à la mer et puis vraiment c'était
formidable colle avec seulement 17
degrés la mer n'est pas très chaude
la plage n'est pas bondée mais les
vacanciers qui ont eu le courage de ce
gta look n'ont pas vraiment boudé leur
plaisir
alors elle est comme l'eau un peu
français
oui j'en viens ça va prendre combien
bienvenue et de l'anase et ça va encore
bien sûr les enfants sont toujours les
plus heureux surtout quand ils
découvrent la mer ou la première fois
comme cette colonie de vacances il fait
beau donc se baigner je crois que c'est
fait ça répond vraiment à leurs attentes
au moins de la première journée
vacanciers heureux mais aussi
commerçants ravi le retour du soleil
sauve le chiffre d'affaires de la saison
ont attiré ça commence là c'est parti
tout ça continue on n'en est pas sûr
météo france prévoit plutôt de la pluie
et du vent
pour le reste de la semaine c'est
officiel les autorités irlandaises ont
fermé formellement identifié aujourd'hui
le corps du navigateur français eric
tabarly repêché vendredi dernier au
large de l'irlande ses amis sur place
ont indiqué qu'en accord avec la famille
il n'y aurait pas de nouvelles
cérémonies religieuses reportage belle
et fonio jacques gérard c'est jacqueline
tabarly qui lui est demandé de venir
reconnaître le corps de son époux lui
yannick le maguer l'ami de toujours du
navigateur français dans la morgue
devant le corps a identifié le compagnon
de route n'a pas hésité
suis tout à fait normal j'ai reconnu
eric les médecins légistes vont de
confirmer à l'instant aucun doute
possible que c'était eric tabarly
une enquête judiciaire de la police
irlandaise a été lancé aussitôt pour
déterminer les causes exactes de la mort
d'eric tabarly dans l'après midi
annick le maguer de retour sur son
voilier a reçu le permis d'inhumer
c'est lui qui est aussi chargé par
jacqueline tabarly d'organiser demain la
cérémonie d'incinération aux fêtes
demain on attend l'avis des autorités de
savoir si eric va être transféré à
dublin pour la cérémonie d'incinération
tel que l'a souhaité sa famille la
cérémonie va être très simple j'ai
demandé à l'initiative de jacqueline
ascain un curé un prêtre catholique ses
bénédictions et puis
voilà je crois que geof est simple dans
l'aîné de la famille de jacques et
derrick opus parce que c'est comme ça et
c'est pour rester fidèle à son ami le
grand tabarly que yannick le maguer
détourné sa route rejoint l'irlande pour
être là dans les bons et pire moment
comment seront rapatriés les cendres
d'eric tabarly c'est sa femme jacqueline
qui va le décider
une seule chose est sûre demain le plus
célèbre navigateur de france va
rejoindre les côtes de son prix soit par
avion soit par bateau
six morts c'est le dernier bilan des
accidents survenus en montagne dans les
alpes ces dernières 48 heures il n'est
donc pas inutile de rappeler encore une
fois les conseils de sécurité
élémentaires pour tous ceux qui veulent
s'aventurer en montagne reportage didier
guyot la tyrie simonet aiguille du midi
3800 mètres d'altitude
ici en pleine saison c'est par centaines
que les amoureux de la randonnée de
haute montagne s'élance direction
l'italie le pied du mont blanc ou encore
la vallée blanche en plein été sur le
site de chamonix plus de 5000 personnes
par jour fréquentent ces sommes il ya
une vraie coupure entre la vie et en bas
et l'aviron on le voit donc c'est assez
extraordinaire pour vraiment se vider la
tête
mais si on veut savourer tout ceci avec
plaisir éviter les pièges il faut
d'abord se préparer physiquement à
l'hôpital de chamonix le docteur
marcigny reçoit souvent la visite
obligée de randonneurs mal préparé la
marche en altitude cela ne s'improvise
pas il s'agit pas se lancer à corps
perdu dans un footing en altitude parce
que de toute façon à ce moment là le
corps va vous dire stop
ou alors vous allez avoir une déficience
d'une quelconque option comme un
problème cardiaque
mais savoir bien se préparer c'est aussi
savoir choisir du bon matériel que les
crampons chaussures guêtres vêtements
chauds il en va du confort de chacun
mais aussi parfois de sa survie dès
l'instant où on a le moins de problème
tout comme les emplois beaucoup plus
grave si on aime choquer qui est pas les
poches qui est adapté on a qui mouille
et si on a une moindre foulure au nez
bloqué une heure de temps on nous tout
de suite en hypothermie
ne pas oublier non plus la météo que le
brouillard et le mauvais temps sur
vienne et le danger est alors de se
perdre impossible de retrouver la trace
il faut aborder la montagne avec
humilité et patience ne pas brûler les
étapes mais une fois respecté tout cela
le plaisir est total sur le tour de
france les coureurs qui vont aborder
demain les premières difficultés
sérieuses des pyrénées essaie d'oublier
la sphère de dopage de l'équipe festina
mais les conséquences de cette affaire
ne font que commencer d'abord parce
qu'une autre équipe hollandaise celle la
tvm et elles aussi n'ont pas aujourd'hui
mais dans les mois qui ont précédé le
tour suspecté dans une affaire similaire
est d'ailleurs une enquête a été
officiellement ouverte à reims
reportage à bord nicosie olivier goetz
oui j'ai bien utilisé de le paix au à la
une de ce quotidien flamand l'aveu d'un
ancien champion de belgique alain vanden
bosch corps est alors sous les couleurs
de la tvm
cet après midi il revient en partie sur
ses propos
j'ai rendez vous s'était pas de ceux que
portent les peaux qui fait quoi
c'était autre chose comme la caféine par
les jambes peut-être que j'aurais pu un
peu plus de caféine que le moment je
pouvais faire autre chose pas contacté
les journalistes belges maintiennent
cependant les termes de leurs articles
et notamment l'allusion à le pays dont
alain vanden bosch aurait alors
expérimenter les effets sous suivi
médical ce soir à pau à l'arrivée de
l'étape du jour du tour de france les
responsables de l'équipe tv m ne
cachaient pas un certain embarras
il a fait ces expérimentations tout seul
de sa propre initiative
c'est pas celle de l'équipe le dossier
tvm commence à s'épaissir rappelons que
le 4 mars dernier deux mécaniciens de
cette équipe avait été interpellé près
de reims en possession de quantités
importantes de produits dopants aucune
enquête n'avait été ouverte
réaction des jours à l' affaire festina
le favori du tour l'allemand jan ullrich
réclame des moyens de contrôles
antidopage renforcer affirment qu'ils ne
détruira lui jamais son corps pour une
course cycliste
l'ancien champion français bernard
hinault
j lui aussi il affirme qu'il ne s'est
jamais dopé et que cela ne l'a pas
empêché de gagner cinq tours de france
bernard hinault est toujours possible de
gagner les cours font rien prendre et
bien sûr pourquoi pourquoi on pourrait
pas le faire
est ce qu'il ya un moyen de dire qu'on
peut pas le faire non mais pour
l'instant on est plutôt effectivement
dans l'autre sens vers que les gens mais
je suis mission est généralisée
justement c'est pour ça c'est pour ça
qu'on veut c'est pour ça que je dis moi
qu'il est possible de gagner le tour de
france en étant à l'eau claire c'est
tout et vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui c'est
le cas dans le poteau que la plupart des
coureurs sont dans ce cas là aujourd'hui
tous les coureurs passent au contrôle
que ce soit qui ait eu des contrôles
sanguins y en a eu 135 poussant sur deux
jours les coureurs qui gagnent pas se
contrôler si c'est pas le jour même des
fois ils peuvent être pris deux jours
après donc nous on n'a pas d'autres
moyens et je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
coureurs sont simples et par rapport à
son époque il ya une vraie différence
existe et ça n'existait pas mais les
problèmes de dopage il y en a réellement
est malheureusement il y en a toujours
eu il ya toujours eu des des brebis
galeuses il ya toujours eu des zain qui
voulait devenir des chevaux de course
malheureusement ça se passe faire on
pense évidemment que les meilleurs sont
toujours les meilleurs resteront
toujours les meilleurs parce que ce sont
ceux qui ont des qualités naturelles et
qui ont pas besoin de ça
le gouvernement nous en parlerons dans
un instant a bien l'intention de
légiférer dans le domaine de la lutte
contre le dopage en effet les substances
absorbées par les coureurs ou les
sportifs en général sont de plus en plus
sophistiqués et risquent à tout moment
d'échapper au contrôle tels qu'ils sont
pratiqués encore aujourd'hui dans l'
affaire festina par exemple le produit
incriminé dénommé epo n'est repérable
dans le sens que pendant trois jours
mais permet ensuite deux semaines
d'efforts sans risque d'être repéré
françoise valais et en carrosse le p o
olivier eu peut-on parler sans crainte
six athlètes de haut niveau il a testé
ce produit dans le cadre une expérience
scientifique à la faculté de montpellier
le hall et les aspirations pour les cinq
temps c'est assez difficile avec eux
plus on la respire et tous les instants
c'est fabuleux
c'est un plan physique et on est bien
quoi on est on est bien simple il n'y a
pas de limite on sent les formes non
plus resté beaucoup plus longtemps sans
sans exploser
le pérou est en fait une hormone
naturelle d'érythropoïétine nous en
possédons tous elle est produite
essentiellement par le rhin cette
hormone agit sur la moelle osseuse pour
la fabrication des globules rouges
aujourd'hui on sait l'a fabriqué par
génie génétique en médecine on
l'utilisent pour soigner l'anémié ou en
traitement d'appoint pour certains
cancers
pour les sportifs augmenter le nombre de
globules rouges c'est permettent une
meilleure oxygénation du sang
le muscle ne connaît plus la 6e' ne
connaît plus la fatigue et pratique
cette hormone est difficile à détecter
il est vain de vouloir rechercher
l'érythropoïétine le jour de la
compétition parce que l'érythropoïétine
d'une substance qui disparaît très vite
de l'organisme et c'est une substance
dans les faits sont partis c'est à dire
que au moment où les globules rouges
arrivent dans la circulation
l'hormone elle a disparu de la
circulation
mais le pays est aussi dangereuse et
l'épée si le sang avec le risque de
formation de caillots d'après les
médecins il y aurait une vingtaine de
morts dans le milieu sportif
la ministre de la jeunesse et des sports
marie george buffet a ce matin dans une
conférence de passe tracer les grandes
lignes d'un projet de loi qu'elle se
propose de faire débattre au parlement
dès l'automne il faut trouver les moyens
d'endiguer le fléau du dopage pascal
nous c'est bon grégoire aussi oui les
voûtes le soigneur des festina arrêté à
une frontière
c'est la preuve que la concertation
entre le ministère des sports les
douanes la gendarmerie et la police peut
donner des résultats mais il faut bien
reconnaître qu'en matière de dopage
le gendarme est très souvent en retard
sur le voleur la loi doit donc aller
plus loin
un conseil de prévention et de lutte
indépendant des pouvoirs politiques et
sportives tentera d'anticiper les
progrès scientifiques des docteurs de
contrôler et de sanctionner les
investigations seront étendus
particulièrement surveillé les sociétés
commerciales d'activités sportives le
dopage y est monnaie courante
le haut niveau n'est pas le seul
concerné la création de groupes dopage
est envisagée dans les différents
services d' enquête les peines seront
plus sévères par exemple la prescription
de produits dopants sera puni de cinq
ans de prison et 500 mille francs
d'amendé contre deux ans actuellement
l'assemblée examinera ce projet de loi
en novembre prochain
pour en revenir quelques instants
maintenant à la compétition le tour de
france arrive et à pau aujourd'hui avec
son héros du jour le français laurent de
biens depuis 48 heures ce nordiste de 28
ans a quitté le gros du peloton pour
devenir hull numéro un celui que tous
les spectateurs regardent passer et
acclament peloton un emploi c'est
toujours le petit jaune à l'heure de
l'apéro encore un lion en peluche pour
sa fille
encore un beau bouquet pour madame et
bien réussi son pari il garde la
précieuse tunique andorre celle des plus
forts celle des cadors
paris - philippe
je pense que dans une première partie
une journée qui finit comme elle avait
commencé en jaune ce matin dans une
petite chambre d'hôtel près de montauban
le nordiste savourait encore son exploit
de la veille un plaisir partagé par son
compagnon de chambrée et d'échapper
c'était un jour de rouler pour un
maillot jaune bon ben je vais faire
aujourd'hui vont un jour sur la côte a
très mal jeunes aussi et donc nous on a
on en a réalisé un peu un rêve d'enfant
goût monde est bien le tandem fonctionne
à merveille sous une chaleur écrasante
la solidarité a marché le leader jamais
en difficulté pouvait foncer vers pau il
y avait bien six échappés mais leur
avance de 4 minutes 40 au maximum
n'avait rien d'inquiétant
derrière tipoli ni apparemment en pleine
forme semble se préparer à poursuivre
les fuyards mais où surprise à l'insu de
tous types olini met pied à terre
comme l'an dernier le sprinteur déjà
vainqueur de deux étapes s'arrête avant
la montagne c'est un autre bon sprinteur
les auvents de bonn qui remporte la 9e
étape première victoire hollandaise dans
le tour 98
pendant ce temps tranquillement des
biens a pris la 32e place
il a droit à un nouveau maillot jaune et
aux égards de la presse mondiale
le petit gars du nord a mis les gens du
sud dans sa poche
il en profite
son rêve en jaune ne pourrait bien
s'évanouir sur les hautes cimes des
pyrénées l'ancien sénateur maire de
clermont ferrand roger quillot a été
inhumé ce matin en présence du premier
ministre lionel jospin du premier
secrétaire du parti socialiste françois
hollande et de pierre mauroy donc lui
fit partie des trois gouvernements
successifs roger quilliot qui s'est
suicidée je vous rappelle en compagnie
de son épouse qui elle est sorties
d'affaires aujourd'hui pour françois
hollande l'ancien ministre était un
homme lille et assumer son destin en
homme libre dans la sphère du sang
contaminé le président de l'assemblée
nationale laurent fabius a fait savoir
ce soir qu'il ne se pourvoirait pas en
cassation contre l'arrêt il vient de le
renvoyer en compagnie d'edmond hervé de
georgina dufoix devant la cour de
justice de la république
la france en tête d'un palmarès auquel
elle aurait préféré échapper celui de la
violence au travail selon le bureau
international du travail à genève la
france l'argentine la roumanie le canada
l'angle
r sont les pays qui ont rapporté le plus
de cas de violence sur les lieux de
travail peut-être parce que ces pays ont
des statistiques bien tenu mieux tenu
que d'autres en tout cas en tout état de
cause il ya des professions plus exposés
comme chauffeur de taxi domestique
infirmiers enseignants mais à côté de la
violence des classiques il est une
violence plus sournoise au sein des
entreprises
laurent bailly sébastien guibert dans
certaines professions la violence au
travail c'est le lot quasi quotidien
comme quand on est taxi et qu'on roule
la nuit ouais j'avais le métier pendant
16 ans la nuit il ya eu beaucoup de
danger au bout de bagarre mais médias
risque voilà les et caprices parcours
quand on va dans la banlieue chauffeur
de taxi conducteurs d'autobus mais aussi
assistante sociale et même professeur
figure parmi les métiers les plus
exposés et cela sur les cinq continents
selon le rapport du bureau international
du travail dans l'entreprise aussi la
violence physique augmente là encore
partout dans le monde ça va de la rixe
au meurtre en passant par le harcèlement
sexuel dont une salarié français sur
cinq se dit la victime en fait 11 % des
français se disent victimes de violences
physiques au travail c'est le taux le
plus élevé du monde trois fois plus que
la moyenne européenne est dix fois plus
qu'aux états unis
non c'est affreux qu'on peut pas
travailler dans des conditions comme ça
c'est pas possible
autre forme de violence les
intimidations les brimades le
harcèlement comme dans cette entreprise
où les ouvrières ont fini par obtenir le
départ d'un directeur tyrannique mais
ailleurs il arrive que les conséquences
soient terrible pour des subalternes
humilier et terroriser
on a peur quand on est stressé on est
moins compétents ont fait des erreurs et
ces erreurs là ne font qu'accréditer la
thèse des méchants entre guillemets qui
va vous voyez bien qu'elle n'ait que
qu'elle mérite les brimades et c'est un
cercle un cercle vraiment très très
vicieux très très pervers et qui amène
malheureusement nombreux des personnes a
démissionné des missions dépression
suicide alors les associations de
soutien psychologique aux salariés se
multiplient dans celle ci on accueille
désormais jusqu'à 30 appels par jour
attentat à l'explosif l'année dernière
contre les locaux de la mutuelle de la
police à ajaccio en corse des dégâts
matériels importants pour l'instant
aucune revendication
l'opération mains propres poursuit aussi
en corse l'ex président de la caisse
régionale du crédit agricole
françois musso a été interpellé ce matin
par les gendarmes
il est soupçonné d'avoir bénéficié de
prêts abusifs pour une somme de 3 ou 4
millions de francs pas sa propre aux
banques le crédit agricole
l'état continue d'ouvrir le capital de
france télécom il va baisser sa
participation de 75 à 62% il escompte en
récolter 28 milliards de francs
parallèlement 2% du capital de france
télécom sont échangées avec l'allemand
deutsche telekom dans la catégorie des
petites et moyennes entreprises cette
fois ci le succès d'un productions
producteur pardon traditionnel de
limonade installé en lorraine depuis 100
ans très exactement il a trouvé
aujourd'hui un créneau en france et à
l'exportation au japon et aux etats unis
face à coca cola christine bost sylvain
gauthier des bulles mais pas celle que
vous croyez à l'assaut du marché
américain une du mna d'artisanal
française présente dans 70 points de
vente aux etats-unis un produits gourmet
apprécié par les amériques
nous avons goûté la limonade
elle est excellent nous avons commencé
avec cinq cartons de 12 bouteilles
à présent nous vendons 120 douté parce
là norina à broadway qui aurait imaginé
une telle destinée pour l'asnl modeste
limonaderie de munster en moselle 230
habitants
au bord de la fermeture il ya trois ans
la limonaderie centenaire entame
aujourd'hui une seconde vie grâce au
dynamisme de son nouveau propriétaire et
à l'obstination de l'héritier de la
famille g hier nous sommes revenus à un
emballage anciens en faisant fabriquer
une nouvelle bouteille de 75 centilitres
avec ce bouchon mécanique gravé en plus
donc c'est est ce déjà cet emballage qui
attire le regard du consommateur et en
plus notre produit était un produit qui
avait déjà une bonne renommée et les
clients qui ont goûté ça on retrouvait
une boisson de leur enfance rustiques
comme les bouteilles la laveuse et
d'origine si le reste de l'unique chaîne
de production a été modernisé les gestes
qui confère son authenticité à la lorina
ont été conservés
10 millions de chiffre d'affaires
l'année dernière pour 32 salariés
la vieille dame de province fait
aujourd'hui la fierté des habitants du
petit village lorrain elle est la
meilleure du monde a de partout oui et
les p1 donc vous êtes connu jusqu'à new
york a foulé oui c'est bien il faut que
ça change en fait c'est l'avenue une
recette dont le secret est gardé depuis
100 ans une bouteille comme autrefois
ou lorsque l'authenticité d'hyères fait
le succès d'aujourd'hui
l'actualité internationale au kosovo
après les combats qui ont fait des
dizaines de morts à la frontière entre
l'albanie et la yougoslavie des deux
pays s'accusent mutuellement de
violation de souveraineté
chacune des deux parties se déclarant
désormais prête à l' escalade dans le
lyrique l'armée yougoslave fait étalage
de sa prise de guerre des fusils
mitrailleurs mortier mines anti chars
lance-roquettes
au total dix tonnes d'armement sont
ainsi exposés ils ont été saisis lors de
divers affrontements avec des
séparatistes albanais qui selon les
serbes tentaient d'entrer illégalement
d'albanie au kosovo ce week-end les
combats ont été particulièrement
violents des miliciens de l'armée de
libération du kosovo ont tenté de
prendre cette ville doha aux vaches
ils se sont battus au corps-à-corps
maison par maison
les serbes disent avoir tué une
trentaine de ces soldats indépendantiste
à la frontière albanaise d'autres
affrontements auraient fait plus d'une
centaine de victimes
les séparatistes blessés ont été évacués
en partie vers tirana la capitale de
l'albanie où le gouvernement a dénoncé
une provocation des forces serbes et
déclaré avoir mis son armée en état d'
alerte à l'heure où les civils quittent
à nouveau le kosovo par milliers à
l'heure où les blessés emplissent les
hôpitaux de campagne serbes et albanais
s'accuse et hausse le ton
aujourd'hui la france a lancé un nouvel
appel pour l'arrêt des combats et appelé
serbe et séparatistes à négocier
l'intériste musulmans au pouvoir en
afghanistan resserre progressivement
leur étau sur le pays ils viennent d'un
site et des organisations humanitaires a
quitté kaboul et le bureau de la
commission européenne a fermé ses portes
50 morts ces trois derniers jours en
algérie plusieurs attaques de groupes
islamistes armés notamment une attaque
qui a fait 15 morts quinze soldats d'une
caserne située dans le sud ouest du pays
après l'attentât manqué hier à jérusalem
le ministre israélien de la défense est
le numéro 2 palestinien abou mazen ont
annoncé qu'ils allaient poursuivre leurs
contacts à très haut niveau pour tenter
de relancer le processus de paix et
notamment une nouvelle vague de retrait
de l'armée israélienne des territoires
ddt qui est toujours en discussion dans
l'ancienne yougoslavie aujourd'hui
séparés en quatre et indépendant la
croatie qui vient de s'illustrer pendant
la coupe du monde de football renoue
avec la paix avec un tourisme qui fut
autrefois florissant et qui pourrait le
redevenir avec une côte magnifique et
plus spécialement une île au nom
imprononçable qui s'écrit achevée à air
et que l'on présente là-bas comme le
nouveau saint tropez
reportage alain job c'est presque
imprononçable achevée à erbach car la
perle des îles dalle mate sur
l'adriatique en croatie mais il va bien
falloir apprendre à le prononcer ce nom
car les autorités du nouvel état on
pourquoi pas les plus hautes ambitions
notre intention est vraiment d'apporter
ici des taux risque vraiment de bonnes
places des lip
on voudrait bien si c'est pas très
modeste faire vraiment un petit saint
tropez de croire dans ses ambitions par
a des atouts une architecture qui
rappelle les quatre cent cinquante
années de colonisation vénitienne de
lille une nature absolument préserver
avec des collines plantées de lavande
une cause presque inexploité avec des
cris quasiment déserte et surtout un
chapelet d'îlots qui font de voir un
paradis pour les plaisanciers qui ne s'y
trompe pas si l'endroit est encore peu
connu du grand public il a ses
inconditionnels que la guerre serbo
croate n'a jamais découragée
je venu avant les événements que tout le
monde connaît est revenu avec plaisir
pour naviguer c'est beaucoup mieux que
saint tropez
parce qu'il ya beaucoup de moyens on
peut aller où il ya beaucoup plus
d'endroits protéger il ya beaucoup
d'huile c'est plus grave je pense que
c'est le mien est d'être la méditerranée
seulement des plaisanciers aussi riche
soit-il ne peuvent pas à eux seuls faire
vivre lille qui n'a retrouvé qu'un tiers
de ces touristes d'avant guerre et pour
arriver au bout de ses ambitions
il lui faut encore faire des progrès
nous devons apprendre aux habitants
d'ici et à nos enfants à l'école
comment se comporter face à ce tourisme
en attendant il y a des occasions à
saisir des villes la superbe autrefois
propriété de la nomenclatura yougoslave
qui savaient vivre beaucoup plus près de
chez nous dans la vallée de la dordogne
où l'on propose aux visiteurs un
labyrinthe naturel dans ce dédale il
s'agit bien entendu de retrouver son
chemin mais aussi de faire des
rencontres avec des personnages de
légende muriel la saga qui sauf qu'elle
a décidément tout pousse dans cette
vallée de dordogne même des labyrinthe
de maïs aux allures très prononcé de
château médiéval
pour peu qu'on s'en rapproche on tombe
alors dans un monde très mystérieux les
fantômes ont été ceux que l'on n'oublie
pas et apparaissent à ceux qui savent
les raconter mais chic des fantômes qui
errent dans ce château très écolo des
temps modernes un univers où l'on se
perd un poison
sauf les plus malins chez moi j'ai fait
le labyrinthe pour me retrouver à
exactement
donc j'ai pas besoin de gemini perd pas
moins et gk suivra le tracé et je me
retrouverais vita sortie fait chevalier
par ici on croise des légendes vivantes
qui vous enseignent les règles de la
chevalerie part du temps ces mêmes les
enfants qui disent pas en jeu suit ce tv
vous ils ont participé tous les parents
qui sera discipliné et les enfants qui
jouent le jeu es-tu sûr que ton corps
est bien avec toi moi je te dis que tu
te trouves tu rêves fois de merlin
l'enchanteur celui qui t'a le plus
impressionné
ça a été merlin l'enchanteur vilar
vous avez dit bizarre comme c'est normal
dans ce monde de l'imaginaire ou un
marin naufragé vous entraîne à bord de
son vaisseau fantôme
à partir du moment où on arrive à faire
fermer les yeux aux gens allaient faire
pénétrer sur sur le bateau la partie la
partie est en partie gagné quoi avec
peuple sorti tout droit d'un songe d'une
nuit d'été façon shakespeare on revêtira
la vie de foule et voilà j'ai bien fait
de venir dans ce labyrinthe de 5 ha
l'esprit où l'humain ses gars mais ne
faut-il pas se perdre pour se retrouver
soi-même comme la tradition l'exigé
c'est au beau milieu de l'été que les
couturiers présentent leurs collections
du prochain hiver aujourd'hui christian
dior dans les défilés ce qui compte
désormais ce ne sommes ce ne sont plus
seulement les robes présentées mais
aussi le décor est dans ce domaine et
bien les spectateurs cet après-midi ont
été très surpris sophie mais l olivier
robert attention dans quelques minutes
le train va entrer en garde en pleins
départs en vacances à d'après-midi
galliano a planté le décor un quai de
gare pour accueillir une collection
haute couture le boulot c'est de faire
pour déstabiliser la haute société qui
ont le salon diop un coup d'épaulé pour
envoyer balader les conventions figé
depuis des décennies et c'est toute une
histoire rocambolesque qui nous déroule
à l'arrivée du duo riant exclu
d'imaginer la caf face pocahontas fils
d'un chef indien qui épouse un
colonialiste britten
l'action se situe en pleine renaissance
sous le règne de françois 1er et henry
viii
le coeur de la belle balance entre ces
deux cultures pour points et brocart
ouverture indienne la débauche de moyens
est faramineuse des tonnes de sable
transportait sur ce qu est des centaines
de plantes tropicales des essences rares
des épices à foison john galliano
décidément ce qui fait
le seul problème et c'est presque un
détail de cette superproduction c'est la
collection on admire les heures de
broderie la virtuosité de la cour
mais nous ne sommes pas au spectacle pas
plus que sur le tournage 9 les clientes
faisait grise mine au premier rang il
faut les comprendre comment vont elles
s'habillent et la saison prochaine telle
est la question
on l'a dit plusieurs fois sur le déclin
et bien pas du tout le créateur de sex
machine james brown est toujours là et
bien là
soixante six ans après 46 ans de
carrière il a donné hier soir au
festival d'istres son seul et unique
concert en france reportage michel
mompontet philippe naudy james brown
mais comme aucune autre stage d'abord
lui n'arrive pas pour un concert lui
daigne seulement quitté son royaume pour
propager la bonne parole celle du funk
bien sûr le funk musiques noires dont il
est le prophète
le créateur le parrain adulé ses fans
ont un peu vieilli
certes et alors ne riez pas jeunes
jambes
vos grands parents ont sûrement danser
sur itunes good et vos parents vous ont
peut-être conçu sur cette machine
voilà 50 ans que james blonde nous
accompagnent dans un rythme d'enfer 140
albums plus tard et monsieur brown a
toujours la classe comme si le temps
glisser sur lui un pacte avec le diable
pour ralentir le tempo de sa vie dieu
m'a donné un style
il m'a donné le nom de james gosse je ne
m'appelait que james joseph zen c'est
dieu qui a trouvé le nom de james donne
un nom de scène précié qui fera et comme
depuis 46 ans chaque soir prière avant
concerne ma musique c'est une affaire de
mathématiques spirituel ça ne s'invente
pas sur le papier ça vient dans votre
tête mais ça pousse dans votre âme et
james brown dans tout ça je voudrais
dire que james brown est un mec chanceux
et que dieu vous bénisse
vingt minutes plus tard avec 18
musiciens la marmite du festival
d'istres est prêt à bouillir le maître
arrive
à
les gens l'entendent ont commencé son
concert par living in america comment
oublier que ce pays justement le
condamne à six fois à la case prison
drogue bagarre comme d'inévitables
clichés condamnant toujours les artistes
noirs américains
et au vu du concert d'hier soir james
brown semble parti pour une tournée au
moins jusqu'en 2070 ils seront bien sûr
plus mais lui mystère hier soir au moins
ils ensemble est bien capable
or nous quitter le rappel des principaux
titres de l'actualité de ce lundi
d'abord incendie monstre en espagne dans
la région de barcelone en trois jours
treize mille hectares de forêts sont
déjà partis en fumée
le feu continue de s'étendre
raz-de-marée en papouasie nouvelle
guinée les premiers témoins racontent
des vagues d'une hauteur de 10 mètres
on pense qu'il ya au moins 3000 morts du
dopage le gouvernement prépare un projet
de loi pour l'automne mais dès ce soir
sur le tour de france des directeurs
sportifs demandent la mise en place
immédiate de contrôle je sens dans un
instant la météo isabelle martinez je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée si
la prochaine
bonsoir